okay das ist das ist jetzt also das was
jetzt gerade herausgekommen ist verwirrt
mich schon sehr hart hallo mein name ist
luca und herzlich willkommen zur haut
das ist eine website wo man einfach
bilder hochladen kann und der sagt einem
wie hottman ist sie können hier entweder
irgendein foto außer komme ich will mehr
sie hier aussieht der ultra süd und sie
hat als hot netz clever hat sie sie hat
und wie heißt die dann können wir jetzt
hier einfach mal vier nehmen und wenn
wir dann schreitet foto nehmen bekommen
wir als prozess dass er tatsächlich okay
ist allerdings gibt es hier auch die
option dass wir unsere eigenen fotos
hochladen können und da lade ich jetzt
erstmal ein foto hoch von charts mal
schauen was john cena für ein hohes
level hat und john cena john cena wird
hier auf 31 jahre geschätzt wie wir ist
er eigentlich john cena ist 38 jahre alt
aber was nah dran als nächstes foto lade
ich jetzt einfach mal dieses hübsche
bild hier von mir hoch und mal schauen
dass er dazu sagt lipp spielen und das
wird mich jetzt echt interesse ich bin
ich bin aber nicht 22 hey was soll das
denn ich habe versucht so bescheuert wie
möglich zu kommen und das ist ich liebe
diese website
als nächstes foto nehme ich mal ein foto
von einem youtuber und zwar von dem hier
vielleicht kennt ihr den jahr mal
schauen was die website da sagt das ist
auch ich weiß gar nicht ob man das ernst
nehmen soll oder ob das jetzt wirklich
ob der wirklich auch hot gibt es 20 vor
allem wird als gesicht einfach nur der
mund erkannt ist start dieses foto hier
ist das nächste und mal schauen was die
website zu diesem alten bild von einem
gewissen youtuber sei okay re wie vreni
wird die auf 20 jahre geschätzt und ich
glaube registriert ist
auf jeden fall krass ich dachte die
website könnte jetzt nur bei den bildern
irgendwie hat angeben aber ich versuche
jetzt mit diesem bild hier das ist jetzt
schon foto wo ich wirklich hart versucht
habe irgendwie behindert zuschauern also
wirklich mit den augen und mit der
kompletten des
ich bin hart und ich bin das foto wurde
zwei sekunden nach dem ersten foto von
mir aufgenommen
ich bin hier vier jahre jünger als im
glück schätzen die mich als männlich ein
okay das ist das ist also das was jetzt
gerade herausgekommen ist verwirrt mich
schon sehr hart ich habe dieses tolle
foto hier vor mir hochgeladen ich habe
wirklich also behinderter kann man
glaube ich nicht schauen ich hätte mir
natürlich noch irgendwie ne scheiße in
die fresse spielen können aber ich sehe
schon hart dumm aus erst mal sagt er
okay ich bin männlich aber dann bin ich
28 jahre alt in ordnung und dann sagte
er zu mir ich bin hot das kann ich
richtig funktionieren da diese website
so oft sagt dass man irgendwie hat es
obwohl man behindert schaut nehme ich
jetzt mal das bild vom sexiest men alive
das hat mich so bewertet ich habe
einfach gegoogelt sexiest man alive und
das hat wohl 2015 david beckham gewonnen
und der sagt stunning 30 jahre das so
viel älter oder laut google ist david
beckham schon 40 das ist tatsächlich
zehn jahre zu jung geschätzt aufgrund
der tatsache dass er mich erst für 22
dann für 18 und dann für 28 hielt props
an dich liebe website als nächstes foto
lade ich dieses foto von corelli hochuli
ist natürlich jetzt kein mensch aber ich
frage mich trotzdem nice cool elias
heißer als risikolimit hier auch
tatsächlich 24 jahre geschätzt und sieht
angeblich männlich wir hatten glaube ich
als geschlecht weiblich festgelegt oder
mal schauen was die website zu diesem
foto von balu satt und zwar sagt hotspot
männliches richtig 28 nicht an dieser
stelle werde ich das video
wir können als fazit festhalten jedes
lebewesen ist heißer als resi und nehmt
das mit auf den weg